[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you know I've been going through a tough
time at home there was
um
I had a difficult moment with my
daughter
few last week we were sitting down on
the couch
it's kind of a kind of a parenting scare
because we were sitting down on the
couch and she turns me out of the blue
and she tells me my seven-year-old
daughter she tells me that she wants to
be a vegetarian
and now the and she didn't know the word
actually at First she said that she's
she said Daddy what's the when someone
only eats vegetables
that I said vegetarian
and she said yeah I'm that that's why I
want to be
of course I'm thinking to myself no
daughter of my no daughter of mine is
going to be a vegetarian but you know I
realized there were there were signs
leading up to this like for example uh
earlier last summer we were out I was
out fishing with her and she caught like
it was like a bluegill or something and
she pulled the hook out and I guess
caused some internal bleeding it
happened threw the fish back in Catch
and Release and the fish Bob back up to
the surface and was just laying there
right and then she pointed to the fish
and said Daddy why is the fish laying
there I said oh he's probably uh
probably sleeping you know took a lot
out of him
when you caught them and then it started
bleeding and she said what but why
what's the Reds why is it bleeding and
then I had to admit well he's yeah he
might have killed him it's okay though
don't worry she and she was devastated
by that absolutely devastated I think
that was the beginning of her animal
rights activism but anyway
fast forward she tells me she's a
vegetarian
and a pretty distraught over that
because I can't imagine having a
vegetarian in the house but um the next
day I'm talking to her again and she
tells me that uh she decided
that she's a vegetarian but she can
still eat chicken nuggets so she'll make
an exception for that
then the day after that she said that
well I'm a vegetarian but I can eat
chicken nuggets but also of course like
sausage and bacon with breakfast I can
have that
and then each each successive day she
started adding more meat products onto
her vegetarian diet until now she's just
back she's a vegetarian who also eats
meat
which is fine which is perfectly valid
that is a self-identity that I can
respect
uh and and her trajectory of
vegetarianism I think follows a similar
trajectory of a lot of people who you
know announced themselves to be
vegetarian
[Music]
you know one of the one of the the small
joys of Parenthood is uh just seeing the
kinds of names and labels that your kids
come up with
for things
um as they're as they're sort of like
making sense of the world and that could
that could always be a lot of fun
and so I I think it could be fun but
it's also a little terrifying at times
so I did this experience a couple days
ago
um I was at home we were in the living
room at night and my my four-year-old
son who he's always got a ton of energy
he's like a rabid raccoon running around
the house at all at all hours of the day
uh just full full of of energy but this
was it was getting late it was like
eight o'clock
and he he was had more energy than usual
and I was trying to figure out what was
going on with him and then he said to me
he said uh hey Daddy guess what and I
said what they said uh I I found some I
found some wild beans I ate some wild
beans and they've made me strong and
crazy
that's what he said
and I thought for a minute it's like
wild beans
that you ate that have made you crazy
what the hell did this kid find and eat
and I'm racking my brain now because the
thing was he that he finally did he eat
like poisoned berries from outside did
he was he in the medicine cabinet this
is a four-year-old he ate something that
he considers a wild Bean
did he find like a crack rock and eat it
I don't think so I don't smoke a lot of
crack at the house so that he shouldn't
have been able to find that
um and then my but my wife quickly put
pieced it all together and realized that
he had somehow invaded our uh our uh our
pantry and we had a whole bag I guess of
chocolate covered raisins and he had ate
the entire bag I don't know how he got
up there where he found them I didn't
even know we had them he ate the whole
bag and then he was on a sugar high so
that was the answer it could be with it
with a four-year-old though
that could be anything wild beans that's
just a great
you know it's just a there's a it's a
great way of looking at chocolate
covered raisins I suppose now
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of Lord or lady and
gain the respect that you so richly
deserve all you need is a one square
foot plot of land in Scotland
established titles is a Project based on
a historic Scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
Lords and Ladies in English and your
title pack you'll be bestowed with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in edelston Scotland
plus an official certificate which I
have here with a Crest your certificate
features a unique plot Number with which
you can see the exact location of your
land
um title packs from established titles
are a fun and unique gift for any
occasion there are even couple packs
that come with adjoining plots of land
for that special someone in your life
with your certificate you could
officially add the prefix of Lord or
lady to your credit cards or plane
tickets and even your dating profile
established titles commits to preserving
The Woodlands not only in Scotland but
around the planet a tree is planted for
every order they receive and you
probably know this about me that was a
really important part of this deal for
me established titles told me that the
first 200 people that purchased a title
pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within walking distance
of mine depending on how many people
sign up we could build our own kingdom
even we're taking over the globe
established titles is also running a
huge sale right now and if you use code
walls to check out you'll get an
additional 10 off go to establish
titles.com Walsh to get your gifts now
and help support the channel
[Music]
you know one of my favorite things uh
about little kids is the way that they
question things well that could be my
favorite thing and also my least
favorite thing it depends on the
questions they're asking and how many
times they ask the same question in the
context and everything but
the good thing with kids is their minds
are always working and they're trying to
figure stuff out and um you never know
what exactly is going on up there until
they open their mouths as my
four-year-old did last night while he
was sitting on the couch and um
and he he turned to me and he asked
pointing pointing to his older brother
he said Daddy if me and Luke switched
heads what would happen
and I said
well I mean you die first of all so
don't that's the first thing and you
probably make a heck of a mess in the
process so
and it kind of goes silent and he thinks
about it and then I start thinking about
it too
and now I'm now I'm now my wheels are
turning and then I I asked him I said
well okay
what if you did switch heads with him
would you now have Luke's body or Luke's
head like would would giving your head
to Luke mean that you go with your head
or would it be more accurate to say that
you remain with your body and now you
just have Luke's head you see what I'm
saying
very philosophical question and um
and he processed it for a while and
eventually we both agreed that he would
probably travel with his head but it's
an interesting question
and then later on when I was putting him
to bed and we're still talking about
this question of uh removing heads and
everything great thing to talk about at
bedtime
and you know and things are finally
clicking and he goes wait a second daddy
so so I'm in my head
I'm in my bones in my head and he starts
knocking on his head like he's knocking
on the front door trying to communicate
with himself
and then we got it then we started
talking about the Mind Body problem and
neurology and the soul and it was all
very metaphysical after a while
um I say we were talking about that but
it was like I was talking and he was
just sitting there not understanding
anything I was saying but I did make
sure to emphasize putting all that aside
don't actually try to do this please do
not try to take your head off that's all
that should be the main point here
[Music]
you know I was sitting down with my kids
uh dinner last night and uh I asked them
as I always ask them you know what did
you learn today in their in the their
homeschool classes
and in the past I've asked them uh I I
would ask a more a broader question like
uh what happened today or you know what
did you do today
and I realized with kids you got to be
more specific because if you ask a broad
question you know I would always ask
what what happened today and uh the
answer would always be something like uh
well we went outside and we saw
something in the yard and we went up to
it and it was a squirrel he was dead and
he in his his he didn't have eyes
and I would say wow
dead squirrel huh
what else happened anything no that was
it just a dead squirrel
what did you do with the dead Squirrel
oh we played dodgeball with it oh dear
God
get away from you all the black plague
now
um so I get more specific and now I ask
what did you learn today and that could
be a fruitful thing so I asked that
yesterday and um my kids told me that
they were learning about uh one of the
one of the things they learned about was
uh persuasion and uh what what is
persuasion and how do you persuade
people you know especially in the form
of writing
and they were telling me about that and
I said well that's great so let's try
this out can you uh persuade me of
something just try to persuade me of of
something
and uh they couldn't figure out what
they should persuade me of and then of
course my wife was was there and she
chimed in immediately and said oh kids
you should persuade Daddy to get a dog
because we're still doing the dog thing
and uh my daughter made an attempt
and her attempt at persuasion was this
Daddy I am persuading you
you are being persuaded get a dog get a
dog you're persuaded
and I try to explain to her that's not
persuasion you can't just make your
demand louder and louder
but what you're doing here this is like
an exorcism the power of Christ compels
you that's not persuasion
but then I also realized that um
that is basically how arguments go on
Twitter this is she's she's ready for
her own Twitter account I think because
that's that's the way persuasion works
not just on Twitter but in society
generally
[Music]
foreign